vmware site recovery manager is a
valuable tool when used with google
cloud vmware engine i'm darren schmitz
with vmware and in this video series i'm
going to show the configuration
operation and use cases for vmware site
recovery manager used between two
regions
the primary benefits with site recovery
manager is that it allows customers to
protect workloads as well as gracefully
migrate them between sites
also keep in mind that this
functionality can easily be extended to
include a data center on-premises let's
get started the first step in
configuring site recovery manager is
downloading both the replication and srm
appliance installation isos from
vmware's customer connect website
administrators will find it helpful to
download the isos to a management vm
already in the environment for a quicker
deployment once the isos are mounted by
the operating system the vsphere
replication and site recovery manager
virtual machines need to be deployed to
both sites using the ovf template
deployment wizard for the sake of time
the replication and srm virtual machines
have been previously deployed into my
u.s central one private cloud instance
in addition windows serve 001 is the
management virtual machine in the
environment that is being used for
administrative tasks
all of the infrastructure related vms
are placed into the management resource
group to help avoid any resource
contention with the workload vms
below the windows machines is the
workload resource group which contains
all the example virtual machines being
used in this demo to simulate our
production workload
switching over to the networking view
another prerequisite is configuring the
proper networking
in this example the management network
is being used for the windows
administrative vms and the workload
network is dedicated for the application
workload machines
when i switch to the vcenter client for
the second data center all the necessary
virtual appliances needed for
replication and srm have also been
deployed and are ready for initial
configuration
finally the last step needed to prepare
the environment is to configure the
vcenter solution user accounts
the google cloud vmware engine solution
accounts are pre-created accounts in
vcenter that are granted the elevated
privileges needed for srm to operate to
begin this process the cloud owner
account privileges need to be elevated
from the google cloud vmware engine web
interface
this is done by drilling down into the
private cloud resources section and
clicking the elevate link
[Music]
from this screen select the time
interval that is required for the
elevated privileges
usually an hour or two will suffice
then click the i understand box to
acknowledge the warning before clicking
on the confirm button
once the privilege elevation has started
it may take a few moments for the
operation to fully complete
however once the elevation process is
done
a second notification will appear
the cloud owner account can now modify
user accounts but must first be logged
out and back in from the vcenter user
interface to be granted those new rights
once logged back in we need to navigate
to the administration users and groups
where the gve.local domain is selected
to reveal the solution user accounts
in this example the solution user 01
account will be given a new password so
that it can be used as the service
account
it is important to remember that this
same process needs to be completed for
both sites
now that the appliance setup and
solution user account configuration is
complete the vcenter registration
process and site pairing is next check
out the next video in the series to
learn how
to learn more about google cloud vmware
engine visit our site at
cloud.google.com
vmware dash engine
[Music]
you